okay I'm gonna keep this brief
because in 55 minutes I'm playing
Rochelle Moo in round two
last night I played Aaron Jacobsen and
did in a draw and today I'm black
against Rochelle who's a player that
I've never played over the board before
but she's had good results recently and
okay for now I'll do a little bit of the
last-minute opening preparation I
already have an idea what I'll play I'm
expecting deform and I'm planning to
play an opening I've never actually
played before which is knight c6 the so
called Knights tango I think it's a
decent option to try and make things
dynamic early to throw her off at least
throw her outside of her comfort zone
and get a position where at least ideas
will be simple for me so there's a few
moves that I can play here there's
Knight c3 which I think she's had once
and like chess comm game after which I
would play e5 d 597 and I was actually
inspired by Fabiana Carmona who played
this a few months ago in the protest
League and I have a game here where he
just developed normally to make sure
hoops to make sure that block castles
before playing d66 would be a tragic
blunder due to Queenie forecheck so
castling and this is a just very
pleasant structure for Locke to play and
Fabiano played very nicely
yay for slowing down the Queen side and
then very nice move here Nike for
preparing that pawn push
sometimes it just takes one game to to
be inspired to play a certain opening
then that takes g2 is great great finish
so etc etc yeah okay so I think I'd be
happy if I see Knight c3 go back to go
back to this position mates III I mean
like I play efore yeah actually this is
one of the main lines then the bishop
should go to still go to c5 I guess
check the database here
okay Bishop c5 at top level but do I
have here at Bishop e2 uh yeah why can't
take the pawn because rook takes h5 I
should take sticks
retakes they tried a few things in the
end and then black just wants to go for
c6 and Queen b6 any games in this
position
g3 stock fish go c6 in stock fish
there's a little bit biased because it
likes white space advantage King f1 is
very strange let's say mate
it's like Queen c2 looks solid Queen b6
ah Queen b6 Bishop t3 Knight g4
g-46
yeah I think this could quickly like
turn good for Allah
mr. d for coming okay so I don't think
this game is going to be so much about
like specific opening preparation it's
more about just getting a structure
which I'll hopefully be comfortable to
play
sanaya three is another move I have
three prevents a five so after which I
play a six and then yeah there's a few
moves that white can play here I think
between Knight c3 a3 and g3 I think with
Knight c3 and g3 but the plan is the
same just bishop before eventually that
Bishop got to trade it off and go for
some idea like this like d6 and e5 is
probably the best way to justify the
knight on c6 so I think what I'll do
I'll just go through the lines that I
have and then I'll look through some
like high-level games in the night
Stingo so a3 oh yeah so the a3 is this
um a Cobian Caruana game so another
Fabia on the Carloni game it plays d6
and then g6 looks weird but turned out
to be solid g5 is nice a very solid
position if people want to find the full
game you can google it a Cobian Caruana
2017 I think this was played in the
protest League so is that the extent of
like opening preparation I think that oh
there's one more line d5 yeah so d5 I'm
not expecting but just for view yeah
just 95 and then e 6 will come or even
c6 e 4 is interested in me for still nu
6
now you for I think is already like
really good for a black because whites
just overextended Queen h4 as a threat
this is a threat late cyber trapped
because I five yeah it's just a nice
position
fifty-five let's look at X III also
looks solid
well if Knight c3 c5 takes Knight takes
this is also very solid III remember
this fish 56 idea and that before I
super he ate or be six maybe be six mmm
a five
okay sock fish as a few moves rookie and
I like and then a five coming okay okay
so what I'm gonna do is actually first I
want to look at like e4 as a possibility
because I know she's capable of playing
e4 and for this I mean this which seems
so here we see the pairings for round
two I found a video on YouTube for my
friend Costa and he played this as he
played against Rochelle just a few
months ago and she played he four
against him and he played knight c6 one
move one and I think I'm gonna do the
same thing she does it because knight c6
well I just want is the moves from this
game yeah so d-4d six nine three
maybe I would play g6 here but maybe not
six is preferable
oh yeah I'm okay I'll go back to chat
space and just input the moves so she
played Bishop d3 g6 c3 Bishop g7 h3
Castle I'm just gonna input the moves
until I know like the deviation so
castling a5
yeah very simple kind of Kings Indian
setup for whites
oh she played she played Bishop III yeah
cause she was saying castling has made
me more natural but there's you three
still this and then she played d5 uh
yeah this is where kosha played Knights
b8
in this position I play 97 more natural
more typical for Kings Indian and then
there's a nice threat here of night he
takes d5 so for example if like castles
here really like c6 maybe c6 has has
similar ideas 66 c4 or ticks ticks ticks
should be two maybe blacks not getting
anything
the whites even better there so let's
look at this immediately
I mean still very playable physician
yeah I wouldn't mind this so c4 is more
natural b5 what's b5 ah same idea b5
it's a funny move takes me 5 9 e takes
d5 takes an e4 there's so many issues
with B - I guess locked me down a pawn
here there's some comp I don't know how
willing I would be to go into this a6 I
mean - bishop so that's kind of a nice
sort of Banco style gambit
you know I can also play it very safe
like 9 h5 it's probably way more natural
and just go for f5 see this is probably
what I'd go for okay so I'm expecting d4
c4
so we'll stay with Knight Stingo I have
to go soon so let's um let's wrap this
up I'm just gonna filter through some
games
oh we're gonna open up mega database and
it helps to know like if you're gonna
play an opening it helps to know a GM
who's played this opening consistently
this is one great thing about chess face
very easy to filter through and find the
games of any sort of player so Ola God
is known for playing nice tango it
actually didn't know this until last
night I was talking with with Roy
raphson I mentioned I'm planning to play
the next tango and he said something
about bowling on so then I started
checking bowling ons games and if we
look here
is actually a nice interface to if it
loads area okay so d-46 being a little
bit slow then make c6 okay so he's
played this thirty-five times has a very
good score yeah let's look at his his
wins
oh wait people can't see I forgot that
opening the new tab essentia this is a
window I was looking at and we see all
of bogans games here
it's basically an opening tree of his
moves so ok knight c6 played 35 times
the winning percentage is always for
white so he scores very well for a black
alright so I'm just gonna go through
let's click open so Dobrev yeah this
idea d65 yeah I actually saw this game
last night it's a nice game Bishop e2
it's so simple
alright results of I'm getting very
similar when they play e3 you take Queen
e7 let it be 5 here I'm being kind of
quick and lazy just because I'm low on
time so just get instant feedback from
stockfish ah
nice in turn Intermezzo taking taking 95
ok looks Pleasant
okay Bishop c4 I saw this game too
yeah this is a long fight but Pleasant
structure Oh
let's keep going so this is one of these
lines so white place III rather than
efore yes against III the bishop along
the new seven I feel it's a little bit
tight like a six oh wow he for white
just wondered this was wrapping so I
just wondered here okay keep going oh
this is funny
let's turned into like some hippo so a
three so same ideas Caruana
yada yada yeah an interesting position I
mean I want something dynamic so be okay
with something like that sort by result
Ivana
okay so d6 and then g6 here I play d4
and d5
okay so Kings Indian Wow 94 is this a
theoretical move I've been played before
so what's the point after Oh II four
hangs in the end that's nice
maybe slightly Josh okay
Black has never lost this position so
basically a to result keen
yeah maybe slightly more pleasant for a
black ze 5 square has AE file funny move
say rook you more than what happens just
take the bishop okay wait
what does stockfish think take the
bishop mmm also c5 interesting takes
takes ages 6 yeah I mean this looks very
very solid this Bishop could come alive
later okay um I think I'm gonna wrap it
up because the game starts soon I have
to walk to the Chess Club so let's close
out this yeah and again because this is
like preparation this is supposed to be
secrets I'll probably be uploading this
after the tournaments so if you want to
look at the games from the tournament or
find any more information you can check
out the links in the video description
below and I'll see you guys in the next
video